welcome to Google cloud drawing board
where we doodle our way through the
cloud today's topic what is bigquery
bigquery is Google clouds enterprise
data warehouse designed to help you
ingest store analyze and visualize big
data with ease organizations rely on
data warehouses to aggregate data from
disparate sources process it and make it
readily available for data analysis that
supports their strategic decision-making
you can ingest data into bigquery either
through batch uploading or streaming
data directly to deliver real-time
insights as a fully managed data
warehouse Google takes care of the
infrastructure so you can focus on
analyzing your data up to petabyte scale
bigquery supports the same structured
query language or sequel for analyzing
your data which you may be familiar with
if you've worked with ANSI compliant
relational databases in the past if
you're looking to create machine
learning models using your enterprise
data you can do so with bigquery ml with
only a few lines of sequel you can train
and execute models on your bigquery data
without needing to move it around when
it comes time to visualize your data bit
Cori integrates with looker as well as
several other business intelligence
tools across our partner ecosystem now
how do you use bigquery luckily it's
straightforward to get up and running
with bigquery after creating a GCP
project you can immediately start query
in public datasets which Google cloud
hosts and makes available to all the
query users or you can load your own
data into bigquery to analyze
interacting with bigquery to load data
run queries or even create ml models can
be done in three different ways first is
by using the UI in the cloud console
second is by using the bigquery command
line tool and third is by making calls
to the bigquery API using client
libraries available in several languages
bigquery is integrated with Google
clouds Identity and Access Management
service so you can securely share your
data and analytical insights across the
organization now what does it cost to
use bigquery with bigquery you pay for
storing and querying data and streaming
inserts loading and exporting data are
free of charge storage costs are based
on the amount of data stored and have to
rates based on how often the data is
changing
query costs can be either on-demand
meaning you are charged per query by the
amount of data processed or flat rate
for customers who want to purchase
dedicated resources want to learn more
about bigquery check out cloud
google.com slash bigquery